hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to would you rather now I
shouldn't need to explain it again but
again horrible decisions you live with
them for the rest of your life and no
one can ever ever ever redeem you for
your terrible decisions but in this case
it actually works out perfectly for me
would you rather have a wardrobe
completely out of flannel and plaid or
have a wardrobe completely out of denim
I would of course pick the plan in
flannel because that's amazing and oddly
enough my red Flint water right now so I
can't wear it for this episode fine I
would love to have an entire wardrobe of
all different colors of bad than
possible would you rather get stung
repeatedly by a Japanese Hornet or be
bitten once by a black widow spider okay
now if I remember if I remember the
Japanese Hornet when you get stung by it
it feels like getting shot with a bullet
like as far as I remember if I'm not if
I'm not wrong about this Japanese Hornet
it's gigantic
it has a venom which is injected by the
six point two five millimeter long
Stinger and attacks this nervous center
the system and damages tissues of victim
oh god it's not the most lethal but the
potency of the sting is due to the
relatively large amount injected being
stung is extremely painful it can
require hospitalization
uh can still be lethal to people who are
not allergic provided the doses of you
would die I gotta go with the Black
Widow
I can't believe I have to go with that
but the Black Widow was bad there
there's also another thing that if it
stings you or if it bites you I can't
remember I think it's a sting but if
it's a-- Sting's you in men it'll give
you unbelievably painful erections that
can last for ten hours and can rupture
blood vessels I will probably censor a
lot of that just cuz it's horrible but
you guys know what I'm talking about
would you rather be stupid and have a
brilliant kid or be brilliant and have a
stupid kid I think I'd rather be stupid
and have a brilliant kid because I could
live with being dumb I know I could make
that choice I don't want them to not
have the choice of being brilliant or
being stupid so I gotta pull the Forrest
Gump on this one would you rather have
everyone talk to you like a two-year-old
or in a sarcastic tone well kind of
everyone in my life already talks to me
in a sarcastic tone but I mean if
they're talking to me like a do year old
then you know that's kind of nice who
you little markiplier I am oh yeah
little Mark EMU there I've embarked EMU
that sounds great I'd go with that one
that's pretty good to me
big change up in my no way around death
would you rather be President but then
be impeached
after three weeks or have complete power
over the world but then get killed after
three weeks oh well I mean
I could do so much more if I have
complete power over the world because
then I could set a lot of things in
motion and then die that your president
presidents can't actually do all that
much I mean nothing peakins president
over not getting into policy road but in
America presidents don't actually do all
that much it's kind of in the Congress
where the power and so I'd rather have
complete power over the world then die
really people don't want to die
imagine that people don't want to die if
you were trapped in the cave with your
pet you rather sacrifice your pets so
you can eat or sacrifice parts of your
body so that you both can eat oh no oh
no how how die here's the situation how
how long how long until we get rescued
is there any possibility of us getting
rescued is this like what kind of cave
are we talking about here this is
horrible I don't want to make this
choice but I have to if you both are
eating you eat twice as much what if you
get to the point where my legs and arms
aren't enough and then you know my dog
eats me because it's hungry but I can't
find it off because I sacrificed my arms
and legs like I'm not saying chica would
but anything back to new corner can is
very very desperate so in a survival
situation in a survival situation would
you rather watch the Sandlot or watch
The Goonies okay people are probably
gonna roast me about this one more than
the last question I have not seen either
of these movie soap which movie should i
watch down in the comments below I'll
take your suggestion I have not seen
either of these movies I know the grumps
talked about The Goonies but I've never
even heard the sandlot I've referenced
the Sandlot before I think I've
referenced both these movies but I've
never seen it so which one should I pick
eeny meeny miny Judy's if your parents
had to give you one punishment would you
rather live without your phone or
without your your drive on her clean
clothes I'd rather live without my phone
what the hell is that I can do without
my phone it's not even a choice would
you rather listen to the Macarena for
four hours straight or listen to Mambo
number five for our street I got to
figure out what Mambo number 5 is a
little bit God that would be horrible oh
man
the Macarena is pretty annoying too I
guess I gotta go for Mambo number 5
because you can keep the party going for
4 hours and that's not actually that bad
if you walked into a room would you
rather have everyone staring you and
disgust like they do already or have
everyone look away and disgust oh come
on this is exactly what they do because
first they stare and then they look away
oh it's just my life if I could split it
in half I would be happy Oh everyone
hates me I don't know I feel like it'd
be really weird if everyone interrupted
turning one oh you and then just stare
down your they're staring at you the
whole time I mean if they have to look
away and discuss are they not gonna be
able to look at the people there with
and never talk it is it just roomful of
silence in disgust oh yeah is this every
time I walk into a room that this
happens or do I again this is just one
room that I know about then I could back
out of because I never look away cuz
staring at me yeah that's bad would you
rather fight Voldemort or fight Freddy
Krueger well if I'm fighting Voldemort
that means that I'm in a world of
Wizarding and magic and that would mean
that I had at some point gotten enough
training in magic to fight Voldemort
unless I'm just going up fisticuff like
hey Baldy yeah your bald head over here
I'm gonna smash it in
no that's how I do his help against
him but if you're fighting Freddy
Krueger that's horrible I've seen the
movies that does not end well for
anybody and unless you're Jason it still
doesn't end well for anybody so I got to
go Baltimore because the implication of
the environment thank you I'm really
neat about this would you rather eat a
quarter or eat chapstick chapstick might
be poisonous the quarter will go through
sounds out what just because a chapstick
might be flavored it might also be
poisonous you don't take a quarters fine
or the comments down there was whoo-whoo
I'm a slot machine
would you rather sing everything you say
or dance all your movements I'd rather
sing everything I say I hope I'm good
but I don't know maybe I'm not good I
mean I I know I know what I am now but
you guys don't know that I'd rather sing
everything I say that sounds fun it'd be
like that episode of scrubs where as she
heard everything in a musical that would
be awesome
would you rather get paid to read every
book or get paid to watch every TV show
there's a lot of books there's a lot of
books this is every TV show in every
language there's a lot of ups and downs
to this there's a lot of pluses and
minuses I could see one or the other but
the thing is like every book that takes
a lot of time and you got to concentrate
on the books TV show you can do other
stuff while you're doing it you just sit
and you're getting paid to do either one
I don't know I will leave this one to
you guys so let me know which one you
would rather be paid to do it's not just
like a preference thing there's other
things about it because yeah I like
reading books but I also like watching
TV but I mean reading books is a little
more engaging but also remember how much
time it's gonna be done like this isn't
just your job if you want to get paid
more obviously you'd read more so maybe
you could watch moldable TV shows it
works and learn to pull teeth
I don't know it's up to you guys let me
know so thank you everybody so much for
watching I look forward to reading your
comments down below and as always I will
see you in the next video
hey uh what did you Bob out up
officially my favorite game I think I
reached a new low my career